news reports are being believed he
starts working well before the Sun comes
up at 4:30 in the morning until well
past Sun time yet he still makes time
for cycling and even hiking the
mountains around Cupertino which I'm
certain he tracks on his Apple watch
while listening to his Apple music on
his Apple iPhone as an avid hiker tim is
no stranger to the mountains of life as
well as life's valleys he reached the
summit in 2011 when he became CEO of
Apple the valley came in 1982 but not
for him for us because he chose to
attend Albarn instead of to Wayne Tim
let me just say we still want you in
fact we want you so badly we're giving
you a degree today and from now on we
invite you to drop by anytime you can
sit on any class that you want to attend
so Tim grew up just a few hours away
from here on the Gulf Coast of Alabama
as I already mentioned he attended
Auburn University where he received a
Bachelor of Science in industrial
engineering and he continued his
education at Duke University earning a
master's of business administration as a
Foucault scholar now I wonder if Tim
knew at his graduation from Duke that he
was literally destined to become the
Alexander Graham Bell of our time after
do Tim quickly climbed the ranks of the
tech industry joining Apple's senior
leadership team in 1998 and today is the
CEO of Apple a company that has
completely transformed the way people
live now think about that for a second
in a world that depends on technology
more and more every day
Tim's decisions affect all aspects of
human life in matters of privacy the
pace of progress even the nature of
innovation itself this requires that he
confront some of the toughest and most
fundamental issues of our time and by
all accounts he's having a lasting
impact not only on privacy and
technological innovation but also in
areas as broad as Public Health
sustainability and diversity and
inclusion he is an example how one
person makes a difference first is a
signal note then it's a chord
crescendoing into a symphony of change
tim expects a lot of himself but he is
pretty good in inspiring the rest of us
as well as he has said history rarely
yields to one person but never forget
what happens when it does that can be
you that should be you that must be you
it is my pleasure to introduce Tulane
University's commencement speaker for
2019 the maestro himself the CEO of
Apple mr. Tim Cook
hello to Lane
Thank You president Fitz Provost Foreman
distinguished faculty other faculty and
the entire Tulane family including the
workers uh sure's volunteers who
prepared this beautiful space
[Applause]
and I feel duty-bound to also recognize
the hard-working bartenders at the booth
though they're not here with us this
morning
I'm sure some of you are reflecting on
their contributions as well and just as
many of you have New Orleans in your
veins and perhaps your livers some of us
at Apple have New Orleans in our blood
as well when I was a student at Auburn
the Big Easy was our favorite getaway
it's amazing how quickly those 363 miles
fly by when you're driving toward a
weekend of beignets and beer and how
slowly they go in the opposite direction
Apple's own Lisa Jackson is a proud
Tulane along yes she brought the Green
Wave all the way to Cupertino where she
heads our environmental and public
policy ward
we're thrilled to have her talent and
leadership on our team okay enough about
us let's talk about you at moments like
this it always humbles me to watch a
community come together to teach mentor
advise and finally say with one voice
congratulations to the class of 2019
[Applause]
now there's another very important group
your family and friends the people who
more than anyone else loved supported
and even sacrificed greatly to help you
reach this moment let's give them a
round of applause this will be my first
piece of advice you might not appreciate
until much later in your life how much
this moment means to them or how that
bond of obligation loves and duty
between you matters more than anything
else in fact that's what I really want
to talk to you about today in a world
where we obsessively document our own
lives most of us don't pay nearly enough
attention to what we owe one another now
this isn't just about calling your
parents more although I'm sure they'd be
grateful if you did that it's about
recognizing that human civilization
began when we realized that we could do
more together that the threats in danger
outside the flickering firelight got
smaller when we got bigger and that we
could create more more prosperity more
beauty more wisdom and a better life
would we acknowledge certain shared
truths and acted collectively maybe I'm
biased but I've always thought the South
in the Gulf Coast in particular have
hung on to this wisdom better than most
in this part of the country your
neighbors check up on you if they
haven't heard from you in a while good
news travels fast because your victories
are their victories too and you can't
make it through someone's front door
before they offer you a home-cooked meal
maybe you haven't thought about it very
much but these values have informed your
Tulane education to just look at the
motto not for oneself but for one's own
you've been fortunate to live learn and
grow in a city where human currents
blend into something magical and
unexpected we're unmatched beauty
natural beauty literary beauty musical
beauty cultural beauty seemed to spring
unexpectedly from the Bayou
the people of New Orleans use two tools
to build a city the unlikely and the
impossible wherever you go don't forget
the lessons of this place life will
always find lots of ways to tell you
know that you can't that you shouldn't
that you'd be better off if you didn't
try but New Orleans teaches us there is
nothing more beautiful or more
worthwhile than trying especially when
we do it not in the service of oneself
but one's own for me it was that search
for greater purpose that brought me to
Apple in the first place I had a
comfortable job at a company called
compact that at the time looked like it
was going to be on top forever as it
turns out most of you are probably too
young to even remember its name but in
1998 Steve Jobs convinced me to leave
compact Baja
mind to join a company that was on the
verge of bankruptcy
they made computers but at that moment
at least people weren't interested in
buying them Steve had a plan to change
things and I wanted to be a part of it
he wasn't just about the iMac or the
iPod or everything that came after
you
people weren't interested in buying them
Steve had a plan to change things and I
wanted to be a part of it
he wasn't just about the iMac or the
iPod or everything that came after it
was about the values that brought these
inventions to life the idea that putting
powerful tools in the hands of everyday
people helps unleash creativity and move
humanity forward that we can build
things that help us imagine a better
world and then make it real there's a
saying that if you do what you love
you'll never work a day in your life in
Apple I learned that's a total crock
you'll work harder than you ever thought
possible
but the tools will feel light in your
hands as you go out into the world don't
waste time on problems that have been
solved don't get hung up on what other
people say is practical
instead steer your ship into the choppy
seas look for the rough spots the
problems that seem too big the
complexities that other people are
content to work around it's in those
places that you will find your purpose
it's there that you can make your
greatest contribution whatever you do
don't make the mistake of being too
cautious don't assume that by staying
put the ground won't move beneath your
feet the status quo simply won't last so
get to work on building something better
in some important ways my generation has
failed you in this regard we spent too
much time debating we've been too
focused on the fight and not focused
enough on progress and you don't need to
look far to find an example of that
failure here today in this very place in
an arena where thousands once found
desperate shelter from a hundred-year
disaster the kind that seemed to be
happening more and more frequently I
don't think we can talk about who we are
as people and what we own to one another
without talking about climate change
thank you
this problem doesn't get any easier
based on whose side wins or losses an
election it's about who has one life's
lottery and has the luxury of ignoring
this issue and who stands to lose
everything
the coastal communities including some
right here in Louisiana that are already
making plans to leave behind the places
they've called home for generations and
head for higher ground
the fishermen whose nets come up empty
the wildlife preserves with less
wildlife to preserve the marginalized
for whom a natural disaster can mean
enduring poverty just as two lanes on
Molly Keough who's getting her PhD this
weekend her important new research shows
that rising sea levels are devastating
areas of southern Louisiana more
dramatically than anyone expected Tulane
graduates these are people's homes their
livelihoods the land where their
grandparents were born lived and died
when we talk about climate change or any
issue with human cost and there are many
I challenge you to look for those who
have the most to lose and find the real
true empathy that comes from something
shared that is really what we all one
another when you do that the political
noise dies down and you can feel your
feet firmly planted on solid ground
after all we don't build monuments to
trolls and we're not going to start now
if you find yourself spending more time
fighting than getting to work stop and
ask yourself who benefits from all the
chaos there are some who would like you
to believe that the only way you can be
strong is by bulldozing those who
disagree or never giving them a chance
to say their piece in the first place
that the only way you can build your own
accomplishments is by tearing down the
other side we forget sometimes that our
pre-existing beliefs have their own
force of gravity
today certain algorithms pulled toward
you the things you already know believe
or like and they push away everything
else push back it shouldn't be this way
but in 2019 opening your eyes and seeing
things in a new way can be a
revolutionary act summon the courage not
just to hear but to listen not just to
act but to act together it can sometimes
feel like the odds are stacked against
you that it isn't worth it that the
critics are too persistent and the
problems are too gray but the solution
to our problems begin on a human scale
with building a shared understanding of
the work ahead and but undertaking it
together at the very least we owe it to
each other to try it's worked before in
1932 the America American economy was in
a freefall 12 million people were
unemployed and conventional wisdom said
the only thing to do was write it out
wait and hope that things would turn
around but the governor of New York a
rising star named Franklin Roosevelt
refused to weigh
he challenged the status quo and called
for action he needed people to stop
their rosy thinking face the facts pull
together and help themselves out of a
jam he said the country demands bold
persistent experimentation it is common
sense to take a method and try it if it
fails admit it and try another
but above all try something this was a
speech to college students fearful about
their future in an uncertain world
he said yours is not the task of making
your way in the world but the task of
remaking the world the audacious empathy
of young people the spirit that says we
should live not just for ourselves but
for our own that's the way forward from
climate change to immigration from
criminal justice reform to Economic
Opportunity be motivated by your duty to
build a better world young people have
changed the course of history time and
time again and now it's time to change
it once more I know I know the urgency
of that truth is with you today feel big
because no one can make you feel small
feel brave because the challenges we
face are great but you are greater and
feel grateful because someone sacrificed
to make this moment possible for you you
have clear eyes and a long life to use
them and here in the stadium I can feel
your courage call upon your bread
try something you may succeed you may
fail but make it your life's work to
remake the world because there is
nothing more beautiful or worthwhile
than working to leave something better
for Humanity thank you very much and
congratulations class of 2019
[Applause]